this is a production of cornell
university
all right thank you
um i'm alan young i am here today with
ajy consulting
i was asked to provide an overview on
the water withdrawal permit as i have
been participating um both as alan young
of h.a.y consulting and alan young of
erie county soil and water conservation
district
on this for the last six or seven months
i have
tried to speak just about everywhere
that i can i'm trying to get into this
and
i hope to provide you guys with the
information that you need to start
making some decisions on your farm here
shortly as you have until the end of the
month to look at this stuff
all right so the water withdrawal permit
and guidance water withdrawal permit and
guidance
as you guys know um
we started this conversation way back in
2012
and it has
blossomed again
and
hopefully i can provide you with
more answers and leave you with
questions
so if we're ready we'll we'll just jump
into it
so a brief history
in new york state
the regulation of water withdrawal
started all the way back in 1905 when
new york state decided that all
municipal
water withdrawals and water distribution
systems needed to be registered
then in 1989
new york state had a committee that was
responsible for water quality
in new york state they turned that
authority over to new york state dec
in
2011
we
had a draft of what later became the
water resources law
that draft and i guess you have to
understand the context of it
um this law was originally crafted
in a time when new york state was
currently on the fence about
the hydro fracking programs that were
creeping into new york state out of
pennsylvania
they were large water users and and this
was an avenue of control
and essentially what this what they
looked at and proposed in 2012 was
expanding new york state dec's control
over water withdrawal
across all industries
so in
2012
the law the water resources law was
passed
which then gave new york state dec the
authority to create a program
to february 15 2012 also happened to be
the date under which we were informed
that agriculture would fall under this
law and we were required
to register our water use
to be exempt from the law
prior to february 15 2012
on april
april 2013 was the first time that dec
had finalized their regulations
for the permit program
which
we we did not see as part of public
comment we we
spent
you know quite a bit of effort back in
2012
when the law was being proposed making
comments but really the the comment
period for 2013
we did not see the the push from the
industry
and then
331 20 2021
a group of farms across new york state
received a letter as part of a desk
audit that dec had done
over about the the water withdrawal
permit program though those farms were
all farms that had registered their
water use back in 2012
and they had submitted annual reports to
dec that at some point over the previous
decade showed that those farms had
either increased their
their use above the regulatory threshold
or had increased their capacity beyond
what they had reported in 2012
and therefore triggered the threshold to
be on the permit
um there
there's a group of i think the new york
state dc had told us that there was a
group of something like 40 farms in
upstate new york that were outside of
the joint basin commissions
that they had sent these letters to
in
may and in august of 2021
a committee was formed by dec to help
them try to find a reasonable path
forward
the results of those
committee meetings i guess are what led
me to speak to you today
in october and november of 2021
dec held two different webinars the
first webinar in october was held
primarily for the group of farms that
received the letter back in march
and then the other group
the other presentation was really for
everybody
um although i don't know how widespread
the distribution of their of their
outreach effort was
um but this is all going to culminate
in march
march 31st 2022
which is dc's self-imposed deadline
to have all farms that
need to be on the permit
at least interacting with dec to be on
that permit
so who needs a permit
non-agricultural facilities uh are
required
basically if they have the capacity to
withdraw a hundred thousand gallons a
day they require a permit
agricultural facilities are set up
differently under the law
so we have a two-part system
the first part is
you have to meet the threshold capacity
which is that average of a hundred
thousand gallons a day in any 30-day
period or
three million gallons in any 30-day
period
and that's a consecutive 30-day period
um dc created this lovely little flow
chart
so you can ask yourself the questions
you know is is my facility in either the
delaware or the susquehanna river basin
if it is then
you fall under the jurisdiction of
one of the the sub river basin
commissions
if you are in long island then you also
fall under a different
legislative authority
and if not then you're with the rest of
us in new york state and then
do you meet the threshold of 100 000
gallons per day in any 30-day period
or 3 million gallons during any
consecutive 30-day period
if the answer to that is yes
then
did you report your water use
back in 2012
if you did not then you need to be on
the permit if you did
have you added any increased sources or
or the capacity to to increase your
withdrawal
if you did then you're probably required
to be on the permit
in all cases dec is referring people to
the regional permit administrator so
whatever region you're in that's the
region that you go to
i did some some quick math for people um
so that you could understand well a
hundred thousand gallons or three
million gallons sounds like a lot of
water but
it really isn't
so using the rule of thumb
one inch of water a week
is
going to basically
yield uh 0.0833 feet
so one acre is 43 560 square feet which
means that
to for a one inch application over an
acre
that's
3630 cubic feet
3630 cubic feet is 27
152.4 gallons
for a one inch application over an acre
using our threshold for the permit
that's 100 000 gallons divided by the 27
152 gallons per acre means that you
could irrigate 3.68 acres per day
and and be under the permit threshold
um
if you want to look at that as a week
you could you could be irrigating 27.7
or 25.78 acres
per week and and be under the permit and
if we want to just look at the three
million gallons
that's 110 acres of irrigation for a
month
at one inch
so exemptions
if you're obviously below the threshold
then you are exempt from
the permit system
if you registered your water use back in
2012
you still are required regardless of
whether or not you're below the
threshold you are still required to
submit your annual report to dec
um if you never registered back in 2012
and you did not
and you're below the threshold then you
don't necessarily have to
make an annual report to the eec
yeah
if you registered your water use prior
to 2012 even if you were over the
threshold
and you have not added additional
sources or increased your capacity
theoretically you are still exempt
but again you will need to continue to
submit your annual report
if you purchase water through a
permitted facility or fall under the
jurisdiction of a regional commission
then theoretically you are exempt
um and and
each one of those
river basin commissions is going to have
its own permitting system that you're
going to need to be compliant with
some
some quick definitions
and where to find things so
[Music]
this entire program came out of the
water resources law
it defines agricultural purposes as a
farming for crops plants vines trees and
the keeping grazing or feeding of
livestock for sale
or
livestock products and the on-farm
processing of crops livestock and
livestock products
it's important to look at what they used
as a definition under the law and that
was that
a facility
can be a grouping of parcels that are
next to each other or under the control
of the same business entity or legal
responsible party
dec has
moved this
definition around um and right now there
is no clear regulatory definition
other than dec saying that most of this
is going to be evaluated on a
case-by-case site-specific basis
farms with multiple locations could be
considered to be a single facility or
they could be seen as a separate
entities under the permit
dc
has said that
the region the regional permit
administrator will be your advisor on
that
to determine how that's going to work
we
as the committee we submitted
many comments about their definition and
and how things
could align better to allow farms the
flexibility and what dec had
essentially came back to us with was
that they did not want to see people
splitting up their operation
to basically skirt the permit
so the basic process for getting through
the permit system
you need to forecast your water needs
well in advance
dc's position is that no new water
source can be used until it's permitted
the permitted facility needs a permit
modification to increase capacity or to
add additional sources
so
dc expects that when farms have
a need for additional water well in
advance they're going to contact the eec
and schedule a pre-application
consultation at the farm
dc's plan is that hopefully a meeting
with the regional
permit administrator will help to
skirt any issues that might become
complicating factors and trying to get
you a permit
so that'll include looking at where
you're going to site it is it near
wetlands a stream that it might have an
impact on is it near other people's
wells
there's a whole slew of of check boxes
that they're supposedly going to have on
a form so that they can help advise you
the best that they can
after you've contacted dec and had your
pre-application meeting
you're going to need to hire a
agricultural well you're going to need
to hire a licensed engineer
in new york state so that they can
help you submit the paperwork as dc is
looking for qualified individuals and
they have named
engineers licensed in the state of new
york as those qualified individuals to
sign off on the reports
i would also suggest that you contact
your well driller at the same time to
make sure that everybody is on the same
page
you're going to need to work with the
well driller and your engineer and dec
to plan your pump test
and if needed your step down test and
then coordinate seeker
which is new york state's version of the
environmental compliance stuff
with endangered species
and then you have shippo the state
office of historic preservation and
looking for culturally sensitive areas
that
may or may not require investigation
before you're allowed to do earth
disturbing activity
the permit is seen as the as the
government action that then requires
the shippo investigation if you fall
within the shaded gray area
and then you may need additional permits
through dec for stream bank disturbance
and i mean theoretically if your site is
large enough you could also fall under
the stormwater
regulations
for the swift program
so once you have all of this set you get
to install the well and necessary
monitoring wells and other
pertinences you will complete the
72-hour pump test you will compile your
studies and reports into the application
package and submit that to dec with your
permit application
and await dec's decision on whether or
not you can
or cannot use that well
um based on its its
calculated impact or if you could use
that well
but there will be conditions upon your
withdrawal
this process looks very similar for
surface water withdrawal obviously there
will be no 72 hour pump test
but what will happen is your engineer
will have to work with dec to calculate
a safe pass by flow calculation
that safe pass by flow calculation
ensures that there is enough water in
whatever whatever surface water body you
would be withdrawing from so that it
does not negatively impact or is not
detrimental to
the ecology of the the ecology of the
water body
and it does not eliminate anybody else's
downstream ability to use the water
renewals permits are only valid for a
maximum of 10 years um dc has indicated
that
it is unlikely that they will be
a lot of 10-year permits most of them
will probably be more like five years
um they are similar to the initial
application except for you will not need
to repeat the pump test
the facility will need to justify its
water use and document all the water
saving technology and improvements that
it is made
modifications uh right now the way that
the law and the ecs regulation reads is
that changes requiring a permit
modification include that are not
limited to
changes in pump capacity the
installation of new pumps enlargements
of conduits increased reservoir storage
installation of new sources of
withdrawal or changes in the diameter of
an existing well
modifications require the submission of
an amended engineers report and the
certification of the new structures
and if we dig a little deeper into the
regulation
that includes distribution lines
from your system so theoretically
buried irrigation lines
would be seen as part of the facility
and the works of the system
and therefore
the modification of that system
could theoretically fall under
the need for a permanent modification
transfers so there is language in
the permit that you know if you want to
purchase or transfer property and
ownership of a water withdrawal system
dec needs to
be notified and approve of said transfer
before it happens
theoretically
if you were a permitted facility then
you would not be allowed to utilize that
new water source on that facility until
the permit is granted dec has said that
they would exercise you know their
enforcement discretion
to ensure that this was not a
major concern
so the tough questions the dec needs to
answer and why they say that we need to
do that 72 hour pump test and the safe
pass by flow calculation are
these eight questions
um dec has said
that in order to answer these questions
this is what they need
from farms
to be able to answer and justify the
granting of a permit um
some of the concerning questions and i'm
not real sure how we how we go about
answering that or having any confidence
in it is that you know um
environmentally sound and economically
feasible water conservation measures um
seems pretty subjective and we're gonna
we're gonna dig into that a little bit
as part of this
um
and then
the adverse you know
this will result in no significant
individual or cumulative adverse impacts
on the quantity or quality of ground of
water sources and dependent natural
resources
i am not sure how we say that we are
going to pull water out and it will not
have it
an impact on the quantity of water
available
items of concern and obstacles for
implementation and compliance
how is water going to be shared if we
are going to set up in new york state a
permitting system
that
basically looks at
the fair and equitable distribution of
water
how how is that going to be regulated
and
the water resources law took this into
account and they
recognized that
the use of water for
municipal and domestic water
shall have the priority all over all
other purposes
but they did recognize agriculture as a
public beneficial publicly beneficial
use
so
at least in in terms of importance maybe
agriculture got a leg up
in future conflicts
but as it stands right now essentially
domestic and municipal purposes have
have the priority
this is
probably at some point would be
litigated i would think just based on
the fact that right now new york state
operates under
the idea of riparian rights and that we
are
a shared youth state so no one
individual should be should have use of
a resource that would preclude anybody
else from using that resource
and if that is
a municipal system that precludes the
use by all other users for all other
purposes
then that doesn't seem to be consistent
with how new york state has prioritized
water use in the past
farms are going to need to develop a
water use conservation plan
this is going to be description of your
near-term and long-term water
conservation use
are you using again this idea of
environmentally sound and economically
feasible water conservation measures
and
what is
what have you done to date and what do
you plan to do in the future
and this is going to require
the use of all known available and
reasonable methods to prevent and
control pollution wastage and
unreasonable disturbance in defilement
of the waters of the state
so
at some point
we
we need to consider how the language of
this bill will impact farms
as it stands right now dc
is using a large amount of its
regulatory enforcement discretion
and
seem to think that they are going to be
reasonable about this but if you look at
the authority that this is providing
them
that in order for them to grant you a
permit you need to tell them all of the
things that you have done
and
so long as
they feel that it is economically
feasible that you've installed
everything that you could
then then you're supposedly fine but
if they decide that
they don't like the fact that people
aren't using pressure compensating drip
tape because it does not have as great
of
a uniform efficiency
to ensure that
the same amount of water is being put
out across the entire field
well they could make that a condition of
granting you a permit for your
irrigation water withdrawals
that you have to use this type of
product or they like this type of valve
because it is less wasteful or that you
must recycle back flush water
or any anything else that you can
ultimately think of that could save
water that might not be
financially feasible to you right now
could be considered there by dec in the
future
permits can be granted or denied or
granted with conditions so under the
authority granted to dec
they more or less can
put forth any condition that they see
fit
and as part of this
dc already has implemented in the
regulation that
all wells will have a static water
elevation gauge
and they should all have
flow meters on them
my question do you see about this right
now dec says that they are fine using
pump runtime for calculating the amount
of
the amount of water being used and and
creating an estimate
and they
would not be implementing the section of
the the regulation that requires the
static water elevation gauge
right now
so inspection of wells is going to be
um right now dec is saying that again
we we aren't looking at this but it is
already written
into the law and they have expectations
that
not only do you have these devices but
the law then states that they expect
that they are calibrated
every five years
so inspection as part of this permit dc
has the right to inspect any part of the
water withdrawal system the water
withdrawal system as i mentioned before
is defined as
any facility works equipment or
infrastructure operated or maintained
for the provisions or withdrawal of
water including but not limited to
collection pumping treatment
transportation transmission storage and
distribution facilities and works
and the facility has a definition of any
or all of the physical components of a
water withdrawal system
so essentially under this permit dc
more or less has the right to inspect
anything
anywhere on your farm
that there is irrigation infrastructure
um we'll talk a minute about the pump
test the 72-hour pump test is the same
72-hour pump test that is expected of
municipal wells
um they are an extremely rigorous test
uh with exacting requirements they
can only be done under certain
conditions
we can't be at a at a high state of
groundwater recharge we can't have
excessive precipitation while
it's happening
we can't be in a drought uh the winter
is probably out you know there are just
tons and tons of
conditions under which this test has to
be done um
we have to shut down the well for 24
hours before the test we have to spend
72 hour continuous hours pumping
um if you don't know what your pump plan
pumping rate is going to be then you
will need to complete a step down test
before doing the 72 hour pump test
there is a requirement
of intensive measurements of water
elevations at and around the wells
and at surface water sources
up to three monitoring wells may
need to be installed for your pumping
test um
so every every surface water source
within a thousand feet of the well which
could be
a stream it could be a wetland it could
be your neighbor's pond
you're supposed to be monitoring
the way the
items that they include in there for for
monitoring these things
indicate that you would need to install
weirs and nesting wells
i again i was told dec would be using
their
their regulatory enforcement discretion
and that those things would not be
necessary but the way that it is
currently written
they are cited as examples
in the permit
if there are any failures during the
pumping
pump test then you're probably going to
have to repeat that pump test
surface water withdrawal i know this is
going to hit home for a lot of
agricultural facilities
you need
dc has an expectation that you know of
all upstream water withdrawals
and they will need that number to be
able to calculate the pass by volume
the procedure is described in a 60 page
document dc says that they will be
responsible for this for the completion
of that pump test or for for the
completion of the
the pass by volume calculation
um
i had a hard time making it through
reading that document and understanding
and following
how that's going to be determined but
essentially
what it means to the farm is that we're
going to need to install some sort of a
staff gauge whether that's in a pond or
a lake or a stream or a river
so that we can accurately look at the
volume of the cross-section of water
moving moving
through
the channel and we would
have basically a number under which if
there isn't x amount of flow in that
channel then we would not be allowed to
withdraw water from it
this is the financial burden to the farm
the
dc will tell you there is no cost for
agricultural facilities to
submit the permit
engineer engineering costs so i've
worked with a couple of engineers across
new york state to come up with
what it would cost
to have them produce these reports and
oversee the pumping test
and
right now it's estimated that it's it's
going to be about 20 000
um
now there there could be some cost
efficiencies there if you're a farm that
is going to install multiple wells
um that
may be in the same area those those
costs could be
shared over those multiple wells but
right now if you're just a farm that's
looking to stick in a single well
um
20 000 could be the cost
from the engineer the
hour pump test
is is most likely
there are a couple well vendors out
there that would provide that test as
part of their services
or you're going to have to hire a third
party but we we've seen those tests cost
25 000
um
then there's the actual cost of drilling
the well that you want to use if it's a
high capacity well you're probably
looking at another 20 000
um the none of the well drillers that i
talked to were the well drillers
association
um really like to put a fixed number
next to anything
but they they said that if you were
planning a budget number
um for a high capacity well twenty
thousand dollars ought to get you in the
ballpark
then there's the cost of installing the
monitoring wells and decommissioning
those monitoring wells
um seventy five hundred dollars a piece
the surface water source monitoring
costs are so site specific that we we
just couldn't
we couldn't come up with a reasonable
number
after looking at several sites and
trying to compare them
shippo phase one and two if necessary is
has been shown through our project work
at the soil and water conservation
districts um at eighteen hundred dollars
to twelve thousand dollars per
per project
um
so you add this all up
we're talking that this is going to cost
someplace
for uh for a 20 000 well that we're
we're going to be spending
probably a minimum of 60 to 80 000
um and then there then there are
reoccurring costs that are part of the
part of the program the permit needs
renewal every 10 years and any permit
modifications
are going to require the the expense of
hiring an engineer to to sign off on
those documents that you're going to
have to submit
and then
failing in abandoned wells
the permit will likely include the
closure and cost of that closure for for
those failing or unused wells
your well driller
is licensed
by new york state dec just like a
business license
well drillers are obligated under under
the law and under threat of losing their
certificate to operate
that they are required to submit a
report before drilling a well
the
information that they have to provide is
who that well is going to be drilled for
and where that well is going to be
drilled in its intended purpose
they submitted report after the well is
drilled
which includes yield data for that well
and then in order to
close a well the
dc expects that
they will submit another notice that
they are going to close a well and then
they have to submit a follow-up report
saying that they actually did close that
well
dc is is well informed about where wells
are going in as by law you have to be a
certified well driller
to drill a well in new york city and all
of those drillers are then obligated to
inform dec about their activities
under the water resources law dec was
granted a
wide scope of jurisdiction
and authority
so
if you read that highlighted sentence
there
essentially the regulations may
establish exemptions from permitting
requirements in addition to those
exemptions specified in this section
dec was given
a fairly blank slate under which they
were allowed to meet and answer those
eight questions that were demanded of
them but other than that they were they
were provided this exemption
it seems to indicate that you know they
they have the ability to create an
exemption
for agriculture
that would extend beyond the 2012
they have not one place the dec is has
cited their regulatory enforcement
discretion is that
after discussions with the committee and
several farms the ec has come to realize
that farms that are reliant especially
livestock farms that are reliant on the
water sources that they have
would not be able to take those sources
offline for 24 hours before a pump test
and for 72 hours after you know during
that pump test and then for a period of
time to allow that well to return to you
know its normal static water elevation
so dec has said that if those farms
who are over the threshold
and need to be on the permit
they would
theoretically exempt the farm from the
pump test
for those existing water sources
installed prior to
march 31st 2022 so long as the farm does
not have any complaints
that they are impacting
a water resource or somebody else as
well negatively
dc has not committed to that action
in writing that they would provide that
exemption
but that is what they have told us
several times
so the equitability problem
most of the questions that were asked
during committee meetings in q a
sessions were
not answered and they were described as
they would be addressed on a
site-specific
case-by-case basis the issue for that
becomes
if each region is deciding
everything on a case-by-case site
specific basin how are they ever going
to uniformly enforce a law across new
york state
we have a very diverse
agricultural sector here in new york
state we have diverse geology we have
diverse
surficial deposits
bedrock deposits so it's very hard to
understand how if everything is going to
be case by case
how you can how you can be reasonably
assured that all of agriculture is being
told the same thing across the state
the broad use of enforcement discretion
is definitely going to lead to disparity
between regions we have seen this happen
time and time again
with capo permitting and almost every
other permit program that dec operates
that has
this large use of enforcement discretion
so
under this the guides of this program
the whole point was to create a system
for monitoring and detecting conflict
over our water resources
but under this program the only people
who are being monitored and permitted
are large are termed large water users
they are probably in the best position
to comply with regulations whereas the
small users who are the most likely
to be
impacted by a large water user and in
the poorest position to get satisfaction
through a court system
are being overlooked by this system
we have brought this to dec's attention
that the reality is if
we are going to operate under an
equitable use of the water resources
that we need to operate a system similar
to what pennsylvania and ohio do
which is that they have
a program in place where they monitor so
anybody who wants to extract groundwater
resources
needs to register their use with with
whatever the environmental entity is in
that state
and if there are conflicts detected then
the the regulator works to create a plan
to resolve
that conflict
the permit does not grant a right to use
water so even if you are permitted
and a neighbor moves in and wants to
drill a well and share in that water
resource theoretically
or or if it's a municipality in this
case they they would have a prioritized
water use
so even even with surface water sources
right it's it's no nobody has the right
to exclusive use of that resource
so additional concerns
the permit will require public
notification and comment periods also
the permit information is subject to
freedom of information requests so
every permit modification will be
required to have public notice as will
transfers and renewals
all of this information will be out
there for people to use which would also
include that
water use conservation plan that you
need to submit to dec would also become
part of the public record
so new york state is lacking a
agricultural engineering
service um
we have a limited number of agricultural
engineers in new york state that are
going to be able to respond to this
request
these are time-consuming reports
and most of our agricultural engineers
are
already lined up with lots of project
work and aren't going to be able to just
drop what they're doing to spend months
writing reports about wells and water
resources
there are certainly other engineers in
new york state
that are available to be hired
it is
very questionable whether or not they
understand agriculture and our need for
water well enough to represent us fairly
is is the way that i would i would look
at that
the length of time that the process is
going to require is something to be seen
how long
will it take to transfer a permit
or how long will it take to get through
this process remember that as a
permitted facility you are not allowed
to use that new water source
until after you've received your permit
modification or your original permit
is this going to take three months to
get through is it going to take six
months to get through
how long depending on when you install
that pump can you know do you have to
wait to be able to perform that that
pump down test
there are a lot of questions up in the
air and this is this goes back there
again why i said that you know you
really under this permit system you have
to know your water need
well in advance
potentially emerg emergency sources were
were another thing that we had brought
up i mean theoretically you could have a
well just sitting on your property that
is not being used
um
that could then be added to your permit
in advance
as an emergency source or you could
identify other emergency sources and
water needs
in the permit again though
generally when emergencies arise
[Music]
we we typically
don't have a whole lot of time to spend
doing paperwork to get a permit
dc has said that they could issue an
emergency authorization
and that they would be able to extend
that i think out past um
originally it would be 30 days that you
would have to use that emergency source
and get the system permitted and they
could extend that i believe at least
once to get you to 60 days and maybe 90.
one of the other things that i would
question is new york state dec's
resources devoted to the program
um you know how many people have they
prioritized are going to be working on
this to help us get through this system
in a reasonably efficient manner
how much training have they done and how
is enforcement going to be carried out
across the state
if you were a farm that chose not to
register your water use in 2012
are you going to be getting a letter in
the mail
because they know that you are
over the threshold and unpermitted
i i don't i don't know the answer to
that question i don't i don't know how
dc's
going to
go about enforcing this rule
dc's current interpretation of the use
of enforcement discretion is likely
to change over time
this regulation certainly could be a lot
more burdensome than it is right now
and we we have not seen
what happens in 10 years from now
using our crystal ball to look forward
that if somebody wanted to they could
definitely use the the way that this
permit and regulation is written
to be much more stringent about the way
that this impacts farms from everything
from looking at
whether or not they think your water use
is reasonable um you know do well you
use too many too many gallons per acre
or you must stop using overhead
irrigation because we can save more
water if we
go to drip irrigation
these are things that could become a
possibility
and we have seen in other states
that they have especially in water
challenge states like california
where
you're not allowed to have
certain types of shower heads because
they use too much water
it's not hard to see that that could
someday come to new york state and and
be a nozzle on an irrigation gun
versus a shower head
in summary
it's my opinion that the current
regulation seems to stand in stark
contrast to the description and general
lack of information given to the
industry
in 2011
to quote our ex-governor this law will
enhance the state's ability to manage
its water to promote economic growth and
address droughts while protecting the
environment and it described it as a
balanced program that manages
significant water withdrawals across the
state and protects new york's farmers
and businesses from undue regulatory
burdens
i have a feeling that the implementation
of this law and permit is going to cause
significant harm to new york state
agriculture in the form of direct and
indirect expenses regulatory burden
the reduction of growth
and the failure to protect our water
resources
not to mention it's going to make us
even less competitive in new york state
as an agricultural sector when competing
against neighbors
questions
hey ellen dave zoodle can you hear me
yes sir
so um just because you've been kind of
up to date on this um have there been
some farms in new york state that have
started to
talk to their administrators
and what are their experiences as far as
um
you know take a farm that kind of knows
they're over the threshold have they had
good luck bad luck are they in process
are they confused
are they already seeing the burden some
of the economic impact
any insight on farmers that have started
the process
um so i know
there are a couple of farms who received
those letters back in march
one of them
was already a farm who was conditionally
certified under
under this program they they were
conditionally they were conditionally
permitted
a year ago
but the reason that they had a
conditional permit was because they were
required to
do that pump test and and this farm was
they can't afford it like
they have
six wells i think that that need to be
pump tested and they
they flat out can't afford to spend that
kind of money
on a pump test
i have
i've been working with another two farms
who were actively working with engineers
right now and
those engineers are working to negotiate
the components of the 72-hour pump
tested dec
um at this point you know everything is
preliminary
um we i i don't think that there's been
anybody who has you know filed and done
or
done their pump test stuff yet
i don't know that anybody has any of
their engineering reports done
i haven't seen anybody who has a shiny
new permit yet
hey alan this is rick simmerman uh
question with regard to the march 31st
2022 deadline what can you advise us in
context to active good faith um
does this permit have to be all
completed by the 31st
or
uh
is it a matter of
starting the process demonstrating a
good faith effort
so from what i've been told by dec
originally their expectation was that
that was the completed
you know permit application in order to
complete your permit application you had
to have done the pump test and all the
other stuff
they they have more or less relax that
to say that as long as you have kind of
contacted dec
that that they would they would consider
that
you you acting in good faith and they
would move forward from there
alan there's some questions in the chat
okay let me see if i can
find that now okay
um
to calculate your facility water
withdrawal do you need to combine all
sources are they treated separately
example stream sources
so that is that is a total withdrawal
for your facility um
so that would be all of your wells and
all of your streams and all of your
pawns all added together
in that hundred thousand gallons is a
total or the three million gallons over
the 30-day period
um it doesn't doesn't matter unless
one of those sources happen to be a
municipal water source which is already
permitted you know under under that
municipality's permit
that water would be exempt or any water
that you theoretically bought i mean i
guess if you want to truck in water for
mayor brothers or something
that that water is already being
permitted for withdrawal under a
different system but any any of your
water sources and and that would be
ponds lakes streams and wells all
together
i received the letter on march 31st 2021
but it does not state whether a permit
whether we need a permit or not does the
letter mean we need a permit
tony what i tell you to do is i'd tell
you to go back and look at what you
submitted to them originally in 2012
and then
look at all of the recent reports that
you have submitted to them and see if
the name of any of the sources changed
that's been one of the things that we
find a lot
is that you know somebody when they
originally submitted it they called it
well two
or or they called it you know somebody's
pond and now now that might have a
different owner or you might just know
it as a different name or you went
through a gap certification process and
you had to give it a real name
it can't be just tony's pond anymore
it's got to be you know
whatever whatever parcel number pond or
address it's that pond and that name
change alone could have triggered dc to
see it as they added a water source
so
it's not
not necessarily that you need a permit
what they are asking right now of you is
hey this looks different than what you
submitted in 2012. it looks like you
were probably over the threshold
and now it looks like you have new water
sources so you know either either
provide us with the information that
says no i don't need to be on the permit
these are really the same thing i just
you know filled it out differently or or
incorrectly which uh
you are so not alone if that happens to
be the case as there were
i i don't know i i'd venture to guess
that maybe
15 to 20 percent of the reporting that
is done yearly
is done correctly
on the right form with the right numbers
from the right places
and this is just a product of
we were given a system in very short
notice
people threw things together
and
now they they've just continued to run
with that information and they've had
very little outreach or education
over the last decade for this
program okay i appreciate it
i think that's what happened us in the
beginning we have the wrong
looks like we
you know we increased our threshold
which which we haven't we've actually
gotten smaller so and we included public
water sources
so i'm telling you
this is this was part of the whole the
whole deal was that we we really were
not provided
the the education and the guidance
component that that we needed to to to
make a
to make a real effort i mean i think 90
percent of everybody out there probably
acted
in good faith and did the best that they
could with the limited information they
had and again we see this as
um
i'm sitting here talking to you today
not a regulator
so i should i should probably go into my
regional administrator and just bring
all this in just
give them a call yeah
yep
okay
yeah i mean i i think that you know you
want to you want to hash this out and
you know it it's better better to know
now i guess
right right um
i i don't believe that long term that
this that this program is sustainable
for for new york state agriculture with
the cost that we're going to incur
like you you might be below the
threshold right now but again
um the the intent and the purpose of
this was that we were going to be able
to monitor and understand the scope of
the water resources used in new york
state and the only people we're looking
at right now use a hundred thousand
gallons a day
um
how long do how long before we need to
know about all the people that are using
less than a hundred thousand gallons a
day
right right i appreciate it thank you
yep
any other questions out there
yeah and this is dan henry a couple
questions or clarifications so on the on
the 72 hour pump test
am i hearing you right that that
actually needs to be done on existing
wells not not just
new wells that are potentially to be
drilled in the future
so if
that depends on
where you pull your information from if
you go and look at the regulation
yes that that expectation would be for
existing wells what dec has said
is that they are
going to
use in their regulatory enforcement
discretion to say that if you have a
pre-existing well that you are reliant
on
and you do not have any official
complaints from any any neighbors or
businesses that you're that you're
impacting their ability to use water
dc has and you
get in contact with them they are saying
that they
they will
exempt you from needing to do the pump
test on those existing wells
okay thank you for clarifying that and
then my second question
um
with respect to rented land so
am i correct in that the the permit
needs to be in the
water withdrawers name not the
landowner's name correct
yes yep that would be
so who whoever's ultimately using the
water is responsible for having it under
their
um their permit okay
so then if i were to i don't know say
have the opportunity to to rent some
additional land in a given year and
there's a pond or a water source on that
property
um
you know and i want to try to plant that
that that particular piece of ground
this this upcoming season
would that be
would you think they would fall under
the emergency use thing or are we gonna
we're gonna have to just wait to get
that
water source for that particular
property added on to our existing permit
once we have it
and just wait for however long that
process is going to take before we can
start farming that land with a crop that
requires irrigation
it seems very likely that they would say
that you need a permit modification to
add that additional source
and we don't know how what that time
frame is right now
we we do not know how long that would
take and and remember you know the the
example that you cited and i think would
be most often the case
is is that that was a surface water
source so now
you're going to need a safe pass by flow
calculation
and theoretically it
ethan dc um
again said that this was a case-by-case
site specific answer when i asked it but
i asked whether or not that
that implication applies to
of making sure that we are meeting the
need of the natural resource as well as
our irrigation water for that path by
flow calculation
that can apply to a pond and they will
consider the littoral zone of the pond a
wetland potentially so if you have frogs
and turtles living in that pond
how much water can you withdraw and keep
them alive became the question and and
that went unanswered
but i think from your standpoint if
you're over the threshold and you want
to go pull water out of that pond then
yes they're absolutely going to expect
you to to add that to your permit
thank you
yep
ellen dave settle again um the regional
administrator can i safely assume that
once you contact them
if you've received letters you're
probably
in the bag anyhow
once you
reach out to that person i'm guessing
you have started the process is that
correct
um i'd also like to think so dave but
right now
um there is nothing to find in the you
know in the agency or the regulation
that they've put in black and white that
says yes
um
that was kind of what people hinted at
was that you know so long as so long as
you've tried to to reach out and and
start this process that they would they
would consider that started um
but
i have no guarantees of that and and
they certainly have not put anything out
in in writing on that
the second part to that question
um you
kind of described it i think pretty well
that new york state is not equipped
right now with the amount of
professional engineers that even
necessarily know
um all the ins and outs and all the
questions to be asked and all the
answers that need to be had but
how well-equipped are the regional
administrators to be giving us the
the um guidance that we need to know
you know should we move forward should
we move sideways
um on on how we're you know approaching
this whole thing if we start putting our
foot in
uh great question dave so what i what i
can tell you is the answer that i
heard at the second
public information meeting that they had
the webinar
that question was brought up
at the end in a short q a session
where people ask you know what what is
the status and the training
um and and how are these people you know
going to be educated to to make these
decisions and answer these case-by-case
site-specific questions
and what the
engineer for
the this division of dec had had said
was that
pretty much
there had been no
formal training
and this is this was back in november
that they had not done any formal
training to the regional permit
administrators
as of yet and that they would
see this as a
regional permit administrators would
work with the state office through dec
in a learn as you go system
okay
that pretty much answers it i think
um
and last question um based on your
calculations at the very beginning
um again every agricultural sector is
different uh the crops we grow are
different the type of soils that we have
are different
but in general
um speaking from the vegetable side of
things are we not
pretty much including
everybody that grows 50 acres of fresh
fruits and vegetables
or more
chances are yes we are okay um i i mean
honestly and and you know this
this overhead irrigation rule of thumb
that i have here um is it my rule of
thumb this is the rule of thumb that
i've heard from half a dozen
farmers that you know you need about
you need about an inch of water a week
and if if that's the case then anybody
who's grown more than 25 acres of
irrigated crops probably falls under
this
i mean but there are some changes there
you know drip irrigation and and plastic
mulch can do wonderful things for et
rates and and maybe we can expand that a
little bit more but at the end of the
day
most commercial growers
are going to be big enough that they
probably reach the threshold
so we're probably talking
hundreds if not thousands of people if
everybody's going to follow the rule
right
yes i i mean
the vegetable growers association i
think has better handle on how many of
you there are out there in new york
state than i would
but i i would certainly guess that it's
a lot more than the
than the 40 farms that were sent letters
um
thank you
yep
i'm gonna put a sign out
survey um if you're signing if you're
leaving and not staying for our annual
meeting please
sign out in the survey if you are
staying
you can sign out at the end and if
there's any other questions or
anything please let me know
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu